the aftermath of a russian cruise
missile strike in jutomium a city 85
miles west of kiev and these are
residential buildings near a hospital
guys there's a man in this house be
careful the firefighter shouts
ukraine's 95th air assault brigade are
based in jutomia the russians were
likely aiming at them
an interior ministry official says four
people were killed
ukraine's wartime president unshaven and
tired looking as he spoke to reporters
work and slept that's it can you see
your family kids no
i can't
when was the last time you saw them
before this war
thank you
i mean just one last question
no not before this war no three days ago
the middle part of this war
yeah then the news that what the
russians had built as a precision strike
on ukrainian communication networks
right by the kiev tv tower has hit the
babinya holocaust memorial site
now it's bombing papiya yes the memorial
yes the memorial which that we made
they started building after
uh 80 years of this tragedy
it's second by br that is russia my
congratulations
russia is picking up the tempo of its
war on its next-door neighbor
eleven people were killed and apartment
buildings ripped to shreds in the
eastern city of kharkiv after a barrage
of artillery strikes on tuesday
including this strike on the main
government building in kharkiv's freedom
square early in the morning
this is a maternity ward in the southern
city of kersen forced to relocate to a
bomb shelter because the sick and those
about to give birth just can't leave
alongside the half a million who already
have ukraine's health minister posted
this picture on his facebook page of a
health worker he says was shot dead by
russian forces as she drove her injured
nephew to hospital in kiev
to the north of the city the 40-mile
long armored convoy bearing down seems
to have stalled a u.s official says it
may have logistical issues or fuel
shortages
key of waits for the storm that is to
come one week into this war that
russia's president swore he would never
wage
[Music]